[Musica]
buon pomeriggio e buon pomeriggio a
tutti quella che avete visto in questo
video è la vita che si respira nella
cascina di mare culturale urbano mare e
culturale urbano è il sogno che ogni
giorno cerco di fare diventare realtà e
rifare rimanere realtà mare è un'impresa
sociale che si scrive in un progetto più
ampio di rigenerazione urbana che il
comune di milano e la fondazione cariplo
sapientemente sostengono nelle periferie
milanesi e consiste nella costruzione e
nella gestione di luoghi dove le persone
possono incontrarsi in nome della
bellezza e non in nome del consumo la
bellezza noi la intendiamo come una
pratica una pratica di costruzione di
condivisione e inclusione una cosa
facile facile insomma luoghi di questo
tipo sono dei centri di produzione
culturale e sono anche dei posti dove le
persone possono stare insieme possono
passare il loro tempo possono stare bene
sono degli hub culturali e sociali dove
artisti e cittadini
respirano la stessa aria e si scambiano
delle necessità per alimentare
reciprocamente il senso del proprio
stare al mondo
a questo punto immagino che molti di voi
stanno pensando che sia che io sia pazzo
e forse forse avete ragione ma ma di
fronte alla coscienza dell'impoverimento
che spesso si circonda
di fronte alla solitudine a cui sono
condannate le periferie
se non si disegna traiettorie che sono
inclusive per tutti di fronte al
silenzio della politica nazionale su
questo tema oggi si gira dall'altra
parte oppure si cerca di fare qualcosa
per alimentare una crescita comune
si cerca di fare qualcosa per far sì che
sa stare bene si sia in tanti e non in
pochissimi è sempre gli stessi accettare
dei muri oppure con tutte le proprie
forze
provare a costruire dei ponti non è non
è un segreto che a milano si arriva
molto spesso per realizzare il proprio
sogno professionale e imprenditoriale
quello che sta succedendo molto spesso
molto più spesso sempre più spesso e che
a milano si arriva anche per coltivare
il proprio sogno esistenziale il mio
sogno mette insieme tutti e tre questi
sogni è un sogno professionale
imprenditoriale e anche esistenziale e
quello che io chiamo un sogno sociale
il sogno sociale più importante del
sogno personale o del sogno
professionale
il sogno sociale si può realizzare solo
se a sognare la stessa cosa sono tante
tante tante tante tante persone
il mio sogno sociale passa attraverso il
desiderio el urgenza e prende le forme
della resistenza e la resistenza per
come io la intendo è una resistenza che
parla di arte di cultura prende le forme
dell'arte della cultura l'arte e la
cultura che non sono più quindi un
oggetto di consumo ma sono una leva di
trasformazione delle persone l'arte che
parte dalla vita che si interroga
discute dei problemi
e delle urgenze della società
contemporanea l'arte che parte dalle
periferie per costruire linguaggi comuni
universali bellezza e qualche volta
anche poesia il posto dove ho imparato
un po sognare tutto questo io credo che
sia proprio il palcoscenico come ho
raccontato ante ed ex che ho fatto
l'anno scorso a milano nella mia vita mi
è capitato di attraversare tante cose
diverse
in particolare un certo punto in maniera
quasi inaspettata rispetto ai percorsi
che stava intraprendendo ho iniziato a
danzare
ho iniziato a fare proprio dal sapore i
problemi e le difficoltà davanti a cui
si trova davanti un danzatore quando si
allena prima e poi quando realizza e
costruisce una performance dopo sono
stati una vera palestra di vita per me e
danzando affrontando i problemi ea
risolvendoli affrontando i dubbi io mi
sono ritrovato adesso nel mio lavoro di
imprenditore sociale a ripercorrere un
po tutte quelle esperienze ea mettere a
frutto quello che avevo imparato danzare
danzare richiede una giusta dose di
leggerezza che attenzione non è
superficialità ma elasticità danzare
richiede consapevolezza di sé nel corpo
dell'altro danzare richiede allenamento
rispetto dello spazio negli spettatori e
soprattutto una cosa importante
l'ambizione ma anche tanta cura e
rispetto del proprio corpo da danza ti
insegna a non separare la testa dal
resto del corpo certo tu non danzi con
la testa ma se la testa non è connessa
al corpo e alle emozioni la danza non
accade
per fare quadrare un pezzo di danza
bisogna bisogna anche saper contare
vi sarà capitato di vedere un film
oppure di frequentare una sala di danza
avrete sentito i danzatori cantare
contare 5 6 7 8
beh se non si sa contare se non si sanno
mettere i movimenti sulla musica alla
coreografia non nasce ma quando le luci
in sala si spengono allora tutto cambia
certo io non vado sul palco per dare
dare dimostrazione di poter contare di
dischi di saper fare tecnicamente delle
cose importanti
io vado sul palco per emozionare per
evocare per dire qualcosa col mio corpo
per fare vivere qualcosa
sono rimasto sempre molto colpito da
come nelle altre lingue si dice imparare
a memoria
in inglese si dice to you die hard e la
traduzione in francese e apprendere
attraverso il cuore viene sempre
chiamato in causa il cuore non la testa
non la mente il cuore un danzatore
quando ha ripetuto ossessivamente
durante le sue prove i suoi movimenti
quando ha costruito alla perfezione la
sua performance ad un certo punto quando
si spengono le luci appunto deve
dimenticare tutto quello che ha imparato
e custodirlo solamente nel cuore
ovviamente io non posso smettere di
contare perché sbaglio non posso
smettere di fare attenzione alle persone
che sono sul palco con me non posso
smettere di fare attenzione allo spazio
ma quello che succede lì è un'altra cosa
quando le luci si spengono diventa una
cosa altra più alta e allora il famoso
qui e ora tutto in quel momento lì e
solo lì
e allora tutti i problemi tutti gli
incidenti che sono molto frequenti anche
nelle arti performative il cosiddetto
bello della diretta
tutti questi problemi devono essere
integrati in quell equilibrio
disequilibrio dinamico che io ho
costruito con i miei compagni di viaggio
non posso fermarmi
devo solo continuare a danzare è
compromesso il compromesso tra il
disegno iniziale e la realtà non può
essere fonte di frustrazione non c'è il
tempo per mostrarsi il compromesso per
il performer divenne un opportunità per
andare avanti
il compromesso per il mio lavoro di
imprenditore sociale diventa una fonte
di conoscenza diventa un'opportunità un
altro modo un'altra chiave di lettura
del mondo siamo spesso portati a pensare
al compromesso come a una forma di
rinuncia
io stesso la pensavo così fino a poco
tempo fa ma poi prima la danza e poi
mare ma quando era un danzatore non me
ne rendevo veramente conto mi hanno
insegnato che il compromesso è davvero
un'opportunità per andare avanti mare è
aperto da poco più di un anno
e così come per la danza
una cosa è la visione iniziale è una
cosa è la realtà come si fa dopo un anno
e ancora e ancora a far stare tutto
quanto insieme come si fa a radicarsi
davvero su un territorio a essere un
punto di riferimento per gli anziani a
essere un'opportunità di lavoro per i
ragazzi con delle storie non facili a
essere un luogo accogliente per le
famiglie ma anche per il rapper di
quartiere un hub culturale e sociale in
una periferia di milano deve essere un
luogo attraversato sempre da tutti età
provenienze sociali e culturali diverse
tutti insieme resistendo alle facili
soluzioni di rivolgersi a un target
specifico di riferimento come permettere
invece che ognuno
si senta in diritto di frequentare mare
quale per esempio il prezzo giusto per
un concerto
qual è l'offerta giusta di cibo qual è
la serie a giusta perché nessuno si
senta escluso
in alto in basso e questo il lavoro
concreto e quotidiano che noi siamo
chiamati a fare e anche in questo caso
anche per queste domande e la danza che
mi è venuta incontro solo se si rimane
davvero connessi aperti alle emozioni al
mondo allora l'esperienza e completa per
danzare bisogna connettere il corpo alla
testa custodire tutto nel cuore e poi
semplicemente danzare la danza e auto
rigenerante
se si cade ti puoi rialzare solamente
con la danza sfruttando il movimento
inesorabile della vita che comunque
inesorabilmente davvero va avanti e
danzando danzando nasce una sorta di
energia indipendente che non può essere
erogata ma può essere solo reindirizzata
e per tenere viva questa energia bisogna
che tutte le persone che sono coinvolte
nella performance avvertono sentano
ascoltano rispettino la propria libertà
indipendenza creatività libertà che non
deve ledere la libertà degli altri ma
bisogna essere tutti insieme per
disegnare dei tratti comuni che sono
all'inizio definiti dal leader che nella
danza il coreografo e nell'impresa e chi
la dirige il compito del leader è quello
di tenere sempre aggiornato quel
tracciato di dare senza sosta l'esempio
di come declinarlo nella performance e
leader come il coreografo o il danzatore
deve
avere molto chiaro l'effetto che produce
la sua danza per produrre quell'effetto
deve ascoltare molto bene quello che gli
accade dentro nel 3 danza deve imparare
ad ascoltarsi ecco io ho scelto questa
metafora della danza per raccontarvi del
mio lavoro di imprenditore sociale
anche perché vi vorrei parlare di una
parte molto molto molto difficile da
condividere con chiunque di questo
lavoro una parte che assomiglia molto a
quella parte a quello che sento quando
quando danzo eppure ha urgenza di fare
quello che si fa indipendentemente da da
un vero e proprio tornaconto personale e
puro istinto di sacrificio che si
consuma e ti consuma solo per continuare
ancora a farlo è puro amore senza
riuscire neppure a capire
l'oggetto di cui si è innamorati ecco io
non ho davvero una parola diversa per
dire quali siano le reali fondamenta su
cui poggia il progetto di mare culturale
urbano i conti i soldi le complessità
gli entusiasmi le soddisfazioni le gioie
e cambi di rotta possono diventare tutta
una questione di amore qui c'è scritto
chi non danza è perduto ma potete anche
leggere chi non ama è perduto
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]